[Music]
so we got some new bill cosby stuff
going on oh
i love bill
you really want to start i love bill
dude
who is his character
very charismatic told me to stop [ __ ]
deflecting man holy [ __ ]
so um bill cosby recently got uh found
liable
yet again
uh for sexual assault again how is he
out something new i still don't
understand wait i think we talked about
this a lot but i still don't understand
why he's even out change.org
that's cool man yeah they got a thousand
signatures
this is for something that happened in
1975. oh wow
that's fishy
why is that fishy
um my statue of limitations you're on
his side no just like for example give
him the fork a lot
like did somebody just come out and say
that he did something in 196 75 or
whatever yes like wouldn't you also come
out at the time when he's first being uh
prosecuted
maybe she just got her new instrument
dude [ __ ] that
70 people were like this dude did this
to me yeah why would he need
like i'm sure there's more people that
haven't said anything yeah i'm just
wondering like why wait for like the
entire thing to happen and then he goes
to jail and then he comes back out and
then just do it again because they're
wanting to get back in jail she
originally um
she originally believed she could live
with it
and then she just started having more
anxiety attacks and flashbacks now that
you know cosby's
out down these streets so she she must
be like in her 70s or whatever well yeah
she's it was 1975 she was 16 at the time
whoa
and uh the way that she says it happened
is that she was with a friend in the
park cosby was there met her and her
friend and then
like i think within like a day or a week
like invited them to party at the
playboy mansion and then he drug him
he did not drug her but uh she says that
what he took her to be alone in a room
and then uh started you know jerking it
and then asked her to do it and then she
didn't want to she she uh i think he
wanted to have sex with her but she she
lied and said she was on her period just
to try to get him to stop yeah but
instead he like settled for like a hand
job and but grabbed her hand and made
her do it until he like came so it's
really [ __ ] like it's very vivid her
mind and i think at first uh of course
the cosby side was denying the charges
and everything but then this came out
where there was an actual photo of her
in him
oh my god
he looks so old there too yeah why does
he look so oh he looks older than the
80s and he looks like a creep there
how did he turn into a grandpa he was
right and he got younger in the 90s and
then got older what the [ __ ] happened
yeah dude he like went back in time
the crazy thing too is this so this has
already uh run its course like the case
and everything and they uh
decided on uh
the the santa monica court jury awarded
the girl who is now you know the woman
and she uh
because there's a story where cosby's on
the phone and they're telling him like
how much the settlement's gonna cost and
they said it'll be 500 000
and he goes literally this is verbatim
he he goes that's it
no way
oh my god is that what he said yeah
that's what he said that was my booyah
no
that's your boya but he literally said
booyah that's crazy that's his you just
had a [ __ ] joke clip of booyah right
now i'm set it up too that's so [ __ ]
solid bro
from his perspective
from his perspective though i get it
because he thought he was gonna lose
like millions yeah and he's like i'm
only gonna lose half a million dude 500k
that's it but it's also [ __ ] sad that
this chick
has been haunted in her mind for like 50
years of this [ __ ] yeah yeah that's a
real tragic dude yeah it is crazy damn
there should be some interest in that
500k from all those years yeah that's
crazy yeah because like look at this
even the headline of this article the
first words booyah oh my god
[ __ ] said booyah
man i can't use that word anymore so
that's
this that clip of jones from 2011 one of
my favorite videos of his of you guys
from back in the day oh this one this
one
and i used to say it the same way after
i saw that i was like that's pretty
funny
how to do that they put your hand in
someone's face
so yeah i imagine when i read that
article i was like because you probably
did the exact same way that's what
that's who joe got it from
man what the hell
i know isn't that crazy dude i wonder
how many like so how many years did he
really do this and get away with because
that's like okay he's been famous since
like the late 60s dude yeah that means
he's probably been running that whole
thing he's been [ __ ]
a predator
for decades and there's no way they're
all gonna catch him like all every
single one of them yeah we have a mutual
friend who know um so he said that uh um
his
it was a makeup artist or hairdresser on
set they were talking and she was an
older lady and she's from that she's an
old school hollywood person and then
somehow the topic of um
uh [ __ ] bill cosby came up and she
goes like oh that guy he definitely did
it and goes why how do you know she goes
because uh when i was doing his makeup
he clawed my boob like this and says
you can't do anything cause i can do
whatever i want
what
there's nothing you could do yeah that
kind of [ __ ] like that's a powerful
folger's coffee in the morning no right
jesus [ __ ] woke up holy [ __ ]
her boob like a claw like ouch like a
[ __ ] eagle claw bro think about how
powerful that fool was back then though
yeah
because ever it seems like everybody
knew about it right like everybody
that's like og in the game everyone has
to cover it up for him everybody has a
story it's also that whole thing where
like
his character is so unlike that to the
public that you sound crazy if you're
like this guy eagle clawed my tit and
he's like a good like father figure on
tv and then just like he's selling
jell-o and he's making money for a lot
of he's selling jell-o i think that's
that's really the key
thing you're making other people rich
and they're dependent on you keeping
this like protection
they're like no you're not gonna [ __ ] up
what i got going no no that's my golden
goose you kidding me that's like how
they protected weinstein because like
there's so many movies everything on the
line people are dependent on him not
being caught and the and the way he got
like kind of i think the way the
headline started happening was from
hannibal burris right like he was on
stage and he started like talking [ __ ]
about bill cosby because i guess bill
cosby had some words about how hannibal
burst would curse
so he said [ __ ] that he what goes on
stage at like a local like new york
comedy show and somebody was recording
and it was this whole set about how he
was like this how's this [ __ ]
gonna talk to me about my language when
he's out here raping all these women you
know and then that clip went viral and
then that's when people started looking
into it and that's why people he got
like he was getting popped for it wow
like that's what like kind of started it
all because everybody was like oh i've
heard that i've heard the same thing
that is
i hypocrisy believe you're talking
you're you're losing those words yeah
that is crazy that he's like he doesn't
curse in his set but he does crazy [ __ ]
richard pryor has bits about it eddie
murphy has bits about
about how bill cosby was a rapist no how
bill cosby would call them up and tell
them how you know
his language and that's [ __ ] lag i
would like to talk to you guys
that bit is so [ __ ] [ __ ] good
and it's it all matches up you know and
it's [ __ ] nuts why is it always the
clean-cut dudes it's always the
clean-cut people that does the evil as
[ __ ] it's like what we talked about last
time right about the whole like part of
the dance community of people doing
everything right on the outside
let's not bring the dance into this
again
you know but like you take you replace
that with any other community right sure
yeah but even like back in our day when
like you know like people were in like
gangs and stuff it was always the pretty
boys that beat their chicks that's true
it was always the pretty dudes that were
beating the crap out of their
girlfriends all the time and they're
like the ones that you feel like would
would never be violent because they're
all sweet and [ __ ] and you're like
they're like pretty boys
and then they're ones that when the
chicks like start telling their story
like wait what the [ __ ] that fool do you
think they get it's because they get
roasted by dudes all day that they need
to find power they need to be powerful
they're a little [ __ ] [ __ ] uppercut
their girlfriend or something probably
to overcompensate you guys better stop
roasting me before i upload bart dude
that's what always made me scared about
uh i used to always have fears that that
would someday happen with mr rogers
because i always felt like he was yeah
yeah i know me too he's the last one
dude that's how i thought about it
he's the [ __ ] last one and then when
the documentary came out i was like
thank you thank you he was a saint but
you don't know though because people can
still get caught after they're dead
apparently
what do you guys think about this let's
say there's a figure right very positive
influence on society put a name out
example yeah like mr rogers whatever
okay let's say they passed away
and dirt comes out after are you guys
more on the side of you know what [ __ ]
it this fool's already dead you can't
really serve justice to him or are you
more on the side of like well there's a
ton of victims that
you know need to get their story out
like should we preserve this person's
like yeah because they're already dead
we can't do nothing about it what side
are you kind of like what happened with
gandhi oh yeah i think you should tell
the whole story because they don't
deserve to be a god
like they don't deserve what about
michael jackson because finding
everybody came out after he died i mean
we all we all saw everything
we saw everything switched so fast
we saw everything there was no coverage
they don't deserve to be a god but some
people can be gods forever
can you remove the artist from the
person
yeah we talked about this all the time
oh you mean like can you see the art
that's right like michael jackson like
still like him as
michael jackson the artist and hate him
as michael jackson the person and what
he's done i love both though yeah he he
he's both
but that's that's different because
michael jackson is still under
like there's it hasn't been proven it's
yeah that's what i'm saying but then r
kelly is different because that [ __ ] is
100 percent proven guilty there's
video proof yeah of the app but the
remix ignition is still playing at the
wedding right our killing fighter
ignition remix there's interviews
kelly's a piece straight up interview of
like have you ever had sex
with teenage girls and he's like
definitely defined teenagers
they're like
oh
would you be a teenager that's what he
said would you mean teenager they're
like come on they're trying to give you
uh like an alley-oop and he still just
fumbled the ball but the song about what
you mean under age the song about him
and the passport on stage in africa
that's the best fire do you have your
people well did they take our killian
spot if i have your shot i don't know
but i think he's back on you come to um
why what did he do
um i think they took him off because of
all the heat when the documentary came
out but it's purely because of the
document hello on spotify yes yeah yeah
yeah i mean they took them off for like
a month so you can remove the artist
from the music because you can cancel
them out but if people want to play the
music it is what it is these numbers
don't lie man look he's still got his
plays and [ __ ] like that's huge what is
it in the millions huh yeah hundreds are
still a piece of [ __ ] but great artist
the answer is yes you can remove i never
idolized r kelly in a way where i
thought he was a um
a good guy i've always laughed at him
you know what i mean like his music is
great
but like his music videos i mean come on
dude the trapped in the closet like it's
pretty [ __ ] oh yeah well he did get
really funny at that point it got funny
it got funny as [ __ ] but even before
that i mean the r b artist of who he was
he was never like the
super cool
like he was no usher exactly he was kind
of goofy yeah yeah no cisco
he's not lou vega
blue vegas lubeck is [ __ ] cool bro
there's no cherry popping daddies
[Music]
you